so do you need a new car key and remote
for your toyota camry well i've got a
solution to you tom's key company has
come up with a way that you can program
these yourself and save a lot of money
over what dealer and locksmith charge
welcome to tomahawk diy i'm mike let me
show you how to do this
you're going to go to tomsky.com where
you can buy a new key if you want one
with remote or you can buy one without a
remote and then you're going to rent
tom's car key programmer this little box
i'll send everything in the mail to you
that you need to take care of this
program it's really easy to do let's
take a closer look now the first thing
with the package will come this little
extension cable you find a little plug
that looks like this
occasionally it might have a cover over
the end
take the extension cable
that'll make it easier to plug in tom's
car key programmer with the extension
cable plugged in we're ready to do this
you got to look around and find where
your blinking red security light is
in this camera it's here on the dash
sometimes up near speedometer sometimes
it's elsewhere with your new remote and
new key that i'll send you through tom's
key company
it's not going to work at first so your
security light
you put it in security light keeps
blinking
that means there's not a valid key
if we put our working key in
see the light turns off a valid working
key
lights blinking
this key doesn't work let's look at the
remote
here's the working remote
unlocks the car
locks the car
makes the alarm
everything's good
if i take my
one that doesn't work
nothing works
i'm going to take your working key on
these camrys it's really important to
take a look at the blade of the key
right here on factory ridge factory
original keys you'll see a letter in
this case it's a g
sometimes it can be an h sometimes it
can be a little dot
some years it changes from one symbol to
another
so you got to be sure you're using the
right symbol that's the chip in your
vehicle you're going to take your
working key
you have the new one that you want to
program ready to go
let's put our new one up here
here's our working one
we're gonna
put it in the security light turns off
you don't start the card just turn it
two clicks to the on position
in the on position
you're gonna slide this little switch i
apologize this doesn't have the label
but when you receive it it'll have a
label one side says key one side says
remote
[Music]
slip it over here to
the key side
get our extension cable we're going to
plug it in
this will start beeping
and we're going to watch the security
light to turn solid red
there it started beeping
watch the light
okay that means it's ready to program
the new key take out the working key
put in the new one see this is uncut
now it starts blinking
will now blink for 60 seconds
[Music]
it's important to watch the blinking
speed it should be about one blink
per second and then it turns off
if it blinks faster than one per second
that means your vehicle has reached the
maximum number of keys that can be
programmed and you need more
sophisticated equipment to erase any
keys that have been lost
all right
there we go after 60 seconds it stops
blinking this key is now programmed
you can take it to a locksmith
they'll charge you a few dollars to cut
it to match your existing key it's that
easy
the blinking light means there's not a
valid key
in the ignition if we put this existing
one in the blinking light turns off
put this one in the bling lights turns
off
so there you have it that's programmed
all right let's take a look at doing the
remote i do want to point out that
process will work for a regular key like
this without a remote i'll sell these on
tomsky.com
programming the remotes
equally easy we're going to take our
existing working key
put it on turn it two clicks to the on
position
have the programmer you slide it over to
where it will be labeled with remote
setting
we're gonna plug it in it's gonna start
beeping
i've got my new remote ready to go
okay that beeping means open the door
it'll change tones you're gonna push
lock and unlock
and then lock
just like that
and you heard it the car beep
signaling that it's done
[Music]
and take out our existing
and unplug this
and now to show you it locks
unlocks
turn on the alarm
[Music]
the trunk button
it all works it's that easy so there you
have it you saw just how easy that was
to program with tom's car key programmer
visit tomsky.com i'll send you new keys
remotes as well as rent out this
programmer there's a deposit fee charge
that deposit will be fully refunded to
you once this gets returned to tom's key
company
there's 100 percent money back guarantee
and all the shipping is paid for both to
send the items to you as well as the
return labels included that'll send them
all back to tom's key company you drop
it in the mail it's that easy so thanks
so much for watching tom tomahawk diy
hope you found this helpful
go visit tomsky.com
if you find that your vehicle isn't
listed yet be sure you leave your email
fill out the form
that will let me know what vehicles
people are looking for so i can get
working on those as well
hope you found this helpful have a great
day